what's the fastest you've ever written a
full screenplay
the fastest i've ever written a full
screenplay
was about three and a half
weeks and
that was writing about four hours a day
and on the road trip that i went on
figuring out where
i was going to move when i knew that i
was going to leave atlanta and pursue
screenwriting
i was lucky enough that a friend offered
his
family's cabin just outside of reno he
said no one is no one's there right now
if you want to stop by and visit you can
use it as a
as a sort of a waypoint nice and
my girlfriend and i ended up stopping by
and
we had just been so exhausted from the
trip and so we ended up staying there
for about
three weeks with his permission we said
hey we think we want to like
kind of sit for a while i want to focus
on a screenplay idea that i have
and can we just kind of take this as
almost almost a month of a retreat and
that is
the only thing i did for those three and
a half weeks that's the only thing i
thought of i was
writing i would get up i would
write for two hours have lunch write for
the two hours have dinner or
something in that order but uh no
casinos no no casinos
no again i would get up i would write
have lunch i would write i would read a
screenplay
have dinner and then i would watch a
movie and both the screenplays that i
was reading
in the evening and the movie i had
picked
as something that was i wanted to either
examine
craft wise or thematically was
similar enough to the story i was
writing so i was just in that mode
all day non-stop and i just wrote that
screenplay and in about three and a half
weeks and i haven't changed
too much of it since
i did a little bit of rewriting but most
of that came out of that
extremely focused work and i don't know
a time in my life that i've had that
sort of
freedom to just create something that is
just purely for me with no
considerations for for job whatever it
was just that was all i was doing i was
essentially paying myself to do that
and it was great it was really fantastic
what time of year was that
in reno um was it winter or no this was
in
september okay so the weather was nice
um i was i was doing that six days a
week
and then one day was uh we would do a
day trip we'd go
we went and we hiked in tahoe we like
um hiked some stuff around reno so
it was six days of focused uh
work and then one day to take advantage
of
where we were did the film get made nope
okay still do you think you'll ever have
it made um
or it was an experiment it was an
experiment i wanted to
try and i wanted to write something
contained and i thought maybe
if i wrote something contained it could
also be a stage play
and so right now the film kind of exists
in this uncanny valley between
stage and screen and is neither a
good it's not really a good fit for
either so
i think if i wanted to seriously pursue
it
i would have to really examine is this
something i want to see
on screen or do i want to make it a
stage play
and
make some craft decisions uh from that
perspective
sounds like though it was a good lesson
and discipline not that
sounds like you you are very disciplined
anyway but to really like
and you're in a strange place where you
want to explore there's lots to do in
reno
yeah um so if it's good so it's not so
good yeah
um you know what i'm saying and so it
was a lesson in discipline like can i do
this
yeah and that was the first time that i
that was the first time that i wrote
something on spec
in a serious way i'd kind of written my
own stuff before but i'm
not in any real
capacity even if even if that's just for
my own
sort of mental state this is the first
time i said i'm going to try and write
something at the end of this
i'm going to try to give it to people to
show that i
can screen write um and
everyone that i've shown it to and we
said great characters great story
but i don't quite know where this
belongs
uh but good writing and so
i moved on to other projects since but
uh we were talking about validation
earlier and that was another
time when i got some validation on
uh a project of mine even though it
wasn't great
it was good enough that people were
seem to be surprised by how oh you're
you can write you're actually pretty
good
we always hear that sort of the romantic
notion of oh i'm gonna
you know go away and write the great
american novel or whatever it is
screenplay
and then too many things that distract
you and get in the way and so i think
just as a mere test of can you keep that
commitment to yourself
that's excellent that's pretty cool yeah
when there's
when there's nothing else going on yeah
it's it's like the greatest thing in the
world to just sit down and just continue
to
write your story but uh
you know that for me uh
where i am right now that's not a
sustainable lifestyle
and uh that's completely focusing
on the uh craft of screenwriting
and i was completely ignoring of course
all the
the career side of screenwriting of
calls and emails and relationships and
everything
so even that as much as i might want to
do that
even if i had the money to do it i don't
think i'd be able to sustain a career
doing that because
you have to do all the other things that
it requires to
make a career in screenwriting and a lot
of that is relationships
you